لذا فإن زخة الشهب الأخيرة لعام 2023
تضيء السماء في الوقت المناسب تمامًا لقضاء
العطلات في ذروتها، فهي تقدم
لمراقبي النجوم
فرصة لرؤية ما بين 5 إلى
10 شهب في الساعة عبر
السماء، دعنا ننتقل إلى  Derek vanam Derek
لم أتمكن من رؤيته بعد ولكنه
يبدو جميلًا جدًا من الصور التي
تظهر تحدث إلينا عنه من أجل
متعة المشاهدة السماوية أعتقد أن
الطبيعة الأم تقدم لنا أه آخر
هدية لها المغادرة لعام 2023
في الوقت المناسب  لموسم العطلات،
وها هو وابل الشهب الخاص بك في
بيكس الليلة التي ذكرتها يا كيت،
هذا هو الأخير من العام، لذا
اخرج إذا كنت من عشاق الهواء الطلق مثلي
وتريد الخروج بعيدًا عن
أضواء المدينة والأقران  نحو
الشمال الشرقي أه، هذا هو المكان الذي
نبحث فيه عادةً عن الدب الأكبر أو الدب
الأصغر، لذلك سيكون لديك
أعلى احتمال
لرؤية تلك الخطوط المشعة من
زخات الشهب تحدث، وعليك أن
تنظر نحو الدب الصغير  هذا هو
المكان الذي ستبدأ فيه في رؤية
الاحتمالية الأكثر ترجيحًا لرؤية حوالي 5
إلى 10 شهب في الساعة، لذا عليك أن
تكون بعيدًا مرة أخرى عن أضواء المدينة
والسماء المفتوحة الصافية أه، سيصل هذا إلى ذروته هذا الأسبوع
والليلة هي ليلة رؤيته  آه،
بلغت ذروتها عند منتصف الليل، في الواقع كان لدينا
شهب من ursids أه الأسبوع الماضي
أو نحو ذلك ولكن في الواقع الليلة هي الليلة
التي يكون لديك فيها أعلى احتمال
لرؤية أكبر عدد من الشهب آه
بالطبع تحتاج إلى سماء صافية
لذلك  ستحدث، لذا لن يحالفك الحظ
إذا كنت متواجدًا عبر
جنوب غرب الولايات المتحدة، فلن يحالفك الحظ إذا
كنت متواجدًا عبر البحيرات العظمى
ولكن إذا كنت متواجدًا على طول الساحل الشرقي مثل
أصدقائي كيت وسارة فقط  ابتعد
عن Big Apple واتجه إلى الداخل
لأنه سيكون لطيفًا جدًا